So as we discussed last night.
We were designed to be.
connected on multiple levels
right in the two sessions that we had last time we
talked about.
The design that we have to be connected emotionally
and physically and spiritually and
intellectually, right? We we
have that design but when life gets busy and
kind of can overwhelm us at times
disconnecting from
each other just happens. It's a it's a
slow fade. We don't intend to it just
overwhelms us and we can kind of
sink into ourselves we can do our alone time.
Those kinds of things we can sure do that and there's
nothing inherently wrong with that.
Right. It's just natural you have
children and you're pulled here pull there
and you have work and those kinds of things and it just
just naturally life just pulls you apart.
That's not a problem. That's not a
problem that happens with cancer signs. There's four teenage girls in my
house. We're kind of pulled away a lot
of times with this year for us.
It's been a challenging year for us and it's
just kind of this.
Slow fade now, it's not necessarily. It
has not necessarily been a problem because
when we notice it we share with
each other.
And in the sharing we just reconnect.
And we're just letting each other know. Hey, I'm still here.
I'm still here.
That's it. So normally.
When life gets busy and it kind
of pulls us apart. Normally we can just say hey, I'd
really like to spend some time with you and just come
back together and it's fine and on we go right we're
securely attached and we just reconnect with
each other.
but it's the moments that we
feel this disconnection
that when we're not able to
share it.
In a way, that's vulnerable.
And it's not received or understood in a
way. That's also vulnerable. That's when Trouble Comes.
that's when the
You know the the protests.
Start coming or if I try in a vulnerable way to connect
with you and early on this is what we do. We try to
connect with each other in some way. But when
that doesn't happen and then we Panic
right the alarm Bells go off then
we oh my goodness. Am I good enough for
you? Do you want to spend time with me can are
you accessible to me? Are you
responsive? Are you going to engage with me? If that's
begins to be a panic for us. This
is when the protest happens.
Right and it's not a stomping crying banging
that guy. It's not always that way. It's just
a little bit more of a drive for us
to connect.
and when that doesn't work now, we escalate that's
what we talked about in the what was happening to us last night what's
happened to us is we escalate it and when you
do that a few hundred thousand times
not even realizing it you begin to
Develop a very clear and predictable pattern. Like
I said driving home. You're lonely need
to connect but you know if I bring this up it's not going
to be accepted. So that's
this cycle. That's what we talked
about last night.
So and it's in those moments really that the
enemy can intensify the attacks on.
It so this morning as we
seek to answer the final question. How do we reconnect?
I want to walk you back through the cycle pretty quickly
here and and I'm gonna use a case scenario kind
of to help you better understand
how it works because the
the biggest step a big
seven maybe not the biggest step a big step
to reconnecting is recognizing
this cycle at
work.
Right recognizing how it's working on us.
So I also want you to see just how fast it
can be just how fast right as I'm
working with couples and I'm talking to them and I'm asking them
kind of tell me a tell me tell me about your last week because
what I'm looking for is I'm looking for something to say. Oh, okay. Sounds
like man the sounds like the cycle came up for you
right here.
And it sounds like it kind of latched on to you right here and
they'll say well. Yeah, I did that well, and
what was that like for you? Well, then I did this. Oh no, but
you missed a whole state. Hold on a second. Let me slow you down. What's when you
did this when when you did this what was happening for you? I'm
wanting them to really slow down and look below the
surface.
Pay attention to what's happening on the inside and that's what I'm hoping you're
doing as we're walking through
this and talking about this.
Is learning as you leave here. I want you to be able to pay attention even more
to What's Happening Here emotionally for us because what
happens for us dictates what we think and
do
right almost immediately.
So we must understand right? So
as we understand as we recognize this cycle, we must understand
just intellectually. We must understand
that we will never connect
the way we want to until
it's safe to do so.
Right, and it will never be safe for us to
do so until we realize what's happening.
Until we know the game. We're playing right the game that
we're playing that dance that we're dancing man. It's
awful dance. It's an it's an awful dance. It's a
it's a destructive dance. It's an awful game.
It's a game that seemingly changes the
rules on us, but it's it can be miserable for
us and it just puts a synonym is miserable place
where it can for sure.
And so this cycle is all about protection
this that's a key point. I want you to understand. This
cycle is all about you protecting yourself.
Right now there is an element deeply there's
an element to it of of protecting our
relationship.
Because if I'm protecting myself from the this feeling
of not being good enough, but I can't share
with you. So I have to show it to you with anger irritation
or silence or something like that. What's really happening
for me? Is this question of disconnection of
of if I'm not good enough
for you.
You could find somebody who is.
So that's the this is the element of I'm trying
to save our relationship to not just protecting myself.
It is an element of protecting ourselves first, but
but there's always this core part that we
deal with as far as the the relationship goes. So
the problem is as because it's about protecting ourselves.
Then it puts our spouse in a place to have
to protect themselves right if I show up at your
house and I've got a gun
You're probably not just going to come right out and go. Hey, excuse
me. Can I help you?
You're probably not going to do that. Right? You're gonna want to come with a weapon.
You're gonna cut white Because You're Gonna Want to defend yourself.
This is the issue is like your anger or your silence or
your criticism is just protection. It just doesn't
look like protection. It looks like a weapon.
And if you bring a weapon then he or
she's gonna have to defend themselves and
now you're both protecting each other or you're both
protecting yourselves from the other and in reality you're
trying to get closer together, but you're being pushed further apart. That's this is
this cycle when they protect themselves
from you and you protect yourself from them now,
we feel more alone than ever both sides. We
feel more alone. And this is what I'm Panic comes
up for us.
This cycle it's a never-ending and self-sustaining cycle.
It will feed itself.
Until we either recognize it and do
something about it, which is what we're talking about this morning or
until you're divorced.
Right because remember the enemy has one goal in
mind kill steal and destroy. Okay. So
looking at this cycle.
Let's go to this next sign looking at this cycle. Let's go back to those
core motions. If you have that cycle there in front of you. That's also helpful
as well. Looking at those look
at those core emotions there. And of course, I've only
listed a few here because these are these are the ones that I really pay
attention to and I realize that those are small, but I'm
hoping that everybody got a got a hand out.
There are many core emotions that get touched.
And it's important to understand what happens to us when
they do get touched.
Right. Obviously, we have the thoughts.
And then we're going to do or say something. This can
be especially important.
This can be especially difficult. Actually,
especially right
to pay attention identify. This is what I'm talking about.
This could be especially challenging for
those of the male gender on the funeral side
of 40. If you know what I mean, right? It's
a little more difficult for us mainly
because what I said last night we have been
trained to kind of disregard or distance ourselves from
those irrelevant or unnecessary emotions.
In a short and I say this all the time this and
primarily I'm speaking about me because I'm
52. I was
for the longest time and to
some degree still am emotionally retarded.
I need to learn I think most men kind of grow up and you
know, we learn in man school that these emotions are
irrelevant. And so we just grow up with not being
able to deal with them not knowing what to do with them. So it's
easy to distance ourselves and adapt and some way and be
The Logical reasonable one and those kinds of in pride ourselves
on that. So as we've been
trained to kind of stay away from those it that makes
it more challenging for us, but we desperately
need help to understand them. This is
why it's a big part of I think you the young man
over here you'd asked last night. Like is this a part of it identifying these
core emotions is helpful. Oh, this guy's got some
of those handouts. If you need the cycle in front of you, especially as
we kind of walk through that. Yeah right there to
you, right?
Okay, so so that brings me to the Second Step Right
recognizing this important recognizing that
the cycle is important recognizing how
it's working is important but the second step in reconnecting
is being able to identify and to communicate
those core emotions. We are
really good at thinking we
are really good at being intellectual. Like
I said, we pride ourselves on that but allowing
ourselves to actually feel the emotions
we feel is challenging and often
uncomfortable, right? This is why I mean
and you think about our culture
We are a culture of pain avoiders.
Right, we don't like pain which is
normal. It hurts. We don't like it and I'm
talking about physical pain. We don't like physical pain.
We especially don't like emotional pain. And so we
avoid that kind of we avoid
that that feeling so we don't allow ourselves to
sit in it and especially some of
those really vulnerable emotions of being
hurt or alone or unwanted or
rejected. We don't like sitting in
those so we get away from those for sure.
Myself personally, I don't know describing my
emotions when I'm feeling absolutely that's
that's what I'm talking about is for
me. We all feel them. That's what I want
you to get is we all feel them.
We just have a hard time knowing describing
what we feel.
This is what when the when you're the teenage
girls like or when we were all kids and all the girls would
go to the bathroom at the same time. They're talking about their feelings and they're we
don't do that.
We're not doing that right there. I'm
kidding. I don't know what they're talking about in.
there but
they right it's kind of the they're just they
just train each other that way right the kind of the universal the
kind of the the universal compassionate is
oh, right. They they women are
just so much better at that historically and not
all women because I've met in my practice plenty of
others that are very intellectual and want to
stay away from that as well.
But you're exactly right. The hardest part is really putting
a label to it and identifying
it and that's where
even asking hey and if
you and if you're feeling if you're in that camp.
And you are feeling something but you're not sure say that.
Tell your spouse you know, she may say hey what's happening for you? What's going
on? And you're like
something but I don't know.
I don't know what I'm feeling.
And and so then maybe trying to describe what it's like and
her helping you. They're really good at helping
us identify what these are so that
is a that's a big step.
So, like I said, we don't like to we don't like to be in it.
We don't like to feel those especially those those painful core
emotions. We like to stay away from those what's more
uncomfortable than actually feeling them is now
because it can be challenging if we don't know what
it is that we're sharing is actually to share those with each other.
That's that's where I know for me. The hardest
part is one. I don't want to look stupid, right? That's a big deal. I
don't want to look stupid. And so
if I don't know what I'm feeling, but I know you're asking for
something you're going to get a deer in the headlights. Look.
Like I know something's happening for me, but
I don't know what it is. And so I just
shut it down or I walk away that's easy to do
that's protective, but it's disconnecting.
So so let me give you an example.
Of the cycle at work. I'm going to put up here. It's it's
a real example, but the names are the names
have been changed to protect the guilty here.
I guess in this kind of situation Corey
and April.
They've been married for 11 years in April's
more recently been concerned about the distance that
she feels between them. Their arguments have gotten
a little out of hand. This is what she said.
And they both recognize that something is wrong. This is what
this right in the quotes is what they're saying. Something is wrong.
It's not sure what it is. Probably like a lot of us.
They both believe they needed help for the last three or
four years, but they just put it off thinking. It's
going to be better. And in reality what I hear from a lot of couples I
used to you know, 10 15 years ago would hear that couples
would putting it off here like
three and four years a lot. But in reality
I've heard in the last 10 years. I've heard that we've waited four
five six eight years after they
know they needed help to go get help.
So this is why I'm glad you're here. If you're in a
place where you need help a sign of a healthy individual is when you need help you
go get help.
And so if you need some help go get it. So it's kind of like them.
They just waited think it ought to be fine. We'll get through it. It's you
know, it's well, he's got something going on his life or she's
got something going on her life or whatever. We'll be fine. We'll get
through it, but they don't.
So they decided to come to therapy after April kind of
in a heated cut made a heated in a heat of a
moment made a comment that really kind of scared him and she
said something about her being done. I'm
done. I don't know how many times I've heard that in my office.
I'm done. I'm done with this.
And and so it's during our work together
what he States is all she does is criticize me.
It's pretty common. She's right. He just feels that and of
course that triggers her. No, it's not what I'm you know, but that's what
he's saying is he just feels criticized and she's States,
you know, everything I do upsets him. I can't do anything. He
just he gets upset and he walks away and
then then, you know as we
kind of get them calling down. She does say she loves him.
She loves him.
But she's at her Wit's End. She just doesn't know what to do. And so
you can kind of see kind of see that. You know, I've tried
to get to you. I've tried to try to try to knock knock you're not
coming. You're not showing up for me.
I'm done. I don't know what to do. I got to give up right
we feel like giving up at times.
and so
looking at this scenario kind of see it here the next
slide. Is that looking at this scenario the queue
there is this cue from April this
perceived distance that she
has and instantly right instantly.
She feels alone and isolated
and sad I'll give you I'll give you
an example of this just so you
can kind of see what I mean. Yeah, you know this summer has
been hot and dry and you know, there's times
in the afternoon and some of those really hot days there
in July, you stepped outside and blistering
heat and you just feel physically
on your skin and your face
and on your right you feel the heat right make sense.
You feel it and then immediately you'll have this thought.
It's hot.
And then you'll say out loud. It's hot now how
that works is you walk outside US. Oh
so hot
And it seems like it's that fast. Well it
is but on the inside you have already felt
the heat you're nerve endings have processed into your
brain and you've you've interpreted that
as heat all that's hot on my skin you think
oh, it's hot and then you'll say it's so hot.
That fast that's how fast this distance can
happen right snake or stick.
remember
so
So she she senses or perceives this distance?
And she feels alone. She feels isolated and she
feels sad and because
This isn't the first time right the first
time she just felt a little.
Oh, I'm just a little lonely. It's not
a lot. It's not desperation. Lonely. It's just a little bit lonely
early on.
Right in year one or year two
or your feet three or whatever and so then at that
point, you know, she would move to him and it was easy. Hey, I'm really missing
you. Can we spend some time together? Can you want to go do something? You want to
go to a movie or you want to watch it show on TV or something? Like it's easy. Oh, yeah,
I'd love to do and so then I reconnect and that's easy or it's well, I
don't have time to that right now at some point it triggered for her right
that it was unable to and that sets off
a small alarm Bell.
And then they just keep going over the years as it
comes up. She begins to learn when I reach for him.
When I see this when I feel this distance.
The loneliness just reappears and it's more powerful and
more profound than it was the last time right because
it's going to escalate.
For them, so she instantly feels this immediately the
thought is yeah. This is just like all the other times. He
doesn't want to be with me. He never wants to spend time with me.
He's too busy for me. I'm not important for him.
I don't know what all the thoughts are very similar to something along those
lines.
And then she protects those core emotions with the
like an irritation right even a frustration
or for her. It's an irritation on this side, right? She
protects those and then in a critical manner,
she says what she's thinking.
You never want to spend time with me.
Well, seeing as that doesn't
sound very warm and cozy to him doesn't sound
very warm and inviting to him. It doesn't say. Oh, yeah, you
really are lonely and you really want me he immediately
feels inadequate right? So that's for the
Arrow coming back down it hits him in the belly you feel inadequate
and then his thought is
nothing I ever do is right.
I'm never going to be able to please her.
Just like that. It happens.
And then he covers up his feeling with frustration.
And he walks away.
right
Now her feeling is she feels abandoned next
slide add to it. Just compounding that
she's more alone more unwanted more
isolated now add to that
abandonment on top of all of those other things.
She's feeling the abandonment.
and
added to the course of the unwantedness not
being wanted.
Covers that up with anger because now she's got to be seen right.
I've got to be seen I got to make
myself bigger to be seen and to be
heard.
And so around they go again.
And you know until I'm not talking to you
shutting down and then she eventually just separates it.
But then In the Heat of one of these arguments, this
is where it comes up for her. I'm done.
I'm done with this.
so
Any of the sound familiar?
You don't have to nod you just in your own in your
brain. Does it sound familiar? Does it feel familiar?
As you're thinking about this.
This is where for me my heart breaks for them.
Because doing what I do.
I get to see I see it. I see it happening and
the sadness for me is they don't see it
happening yet. And I desperately want them to see
this. I desperately want you to see this.
Because there's something happening and always
have to point out to them if he's so awful if he
never wants to be beside you if she is trying to
ruin your life. Why in the world are they sitting here with you on
the couch in my office trying to figure out
how to make this thing work?
If they didn't care, they wouldn't be here. If you
didn't care you wouldn't be here.
tonight today this morning, whatever we're
Okay.
So it all happened all this happens to all of us at one time
or another right we go we all encounter this.
And it's simply like I said last night, it's the
outcome of this long-standing cycle. It's the product of this happening
to us and some of you for years and
years and years. I worked with couples that in there. They're
30s. I got a couple now they've been married. I think they've been married 40.
To for something like that. I want to say it's like 10 years
longer than me. So it's about that long for them and they've
been and as we're talking about it. They're like this this goes
back for us into the 1980s for
them. They remember how long this
has been happening for them and never any idea.
What was happening, so?
So recognizing the cycle at work and
recognizing that is is this force that
says don't be vulnerable.
don't
open up your heart don't share what's happening for
you. Don't do that for whatever reason don't
do that. That's scary. They're gonna think you're soft.
They're gonna think you're weak. They're gonna think you're needy
and dependent don't don't do that. Don't share it that Force.
Is the cycle at work and so recognizing this
is crucial the it's the
first it's the first huge step this identifying it
and then being able to communicate what's happening to each other
these core emotions. That's the next
big step the third big step is
that we must identify our position in
the cycle. So if you look
on your cycle the position is this is what we
do, right? This is what we do or this is what we say. It's
For us to know and to
understand how we respond.
when those core emotions get touched, right what
I do or what I say if I walk away or
if I get angry or my critical or whatever understanding
that position is crucial
the second piece of
this is even
more crucial and that is taking ownership
of what you do and you're
in those moments.
When you say something or do something when
you walk away taking ownership?
Of that position is crucial.
Because in that moment taking ownership of what you
do or say and the impact on your
spouse makes you safer.
Right often use an example of
my office like if if you walk in the door and I punch you
in the nose. Not only
not not only do you
feel the physical pain there?
And I need to recognize the the
physical pain and what I've
caused you but I also need to understand the impact
of that on you and the impact
of that not only is the physical pain you feel but now
the lack of trust that you have in me, right? I get it's a
dumb example, but you get the idea.
I have to understand the impact on you. And
so for us to take ownership makes us safer often
use the example.
I'm not a NASCAR guy at all. I don't know NASCAR and
Tony Stewart. Maybe I don't remember he I don't know if you
know if he's still alive or not. I have no idea but the idea think about
if you know a NASCAR guy or whatever think about this, let's say did
anybody have a 16 year old driver? Anybody have
a brand new or you got a 16 year old driver? Okay, right. Okay good. Someone
use him or hers an example. Let's say
let's say Dad they say
hey, let's go down to Texas Motor
Speedway and let's jump in one of those race cars and let me take you around the track
at 220 miles from an hour you in.
You with your teenager.
We not with your teenager.
Come on.
I got mine. No way not at 220
miles an hour not with them.
They're not they don't handle their vehicle there. They're not
gonna be able to handle the turns and it's going to be it's going
to end in a fiery crash. Right just a hundred percent. But let's
say, you know like 12 times. Let's say
I'm a 12 time NASCAR champion and I call you and go. Hey, I'm gonna
be in town. We're all friends. Why don't you
come down? Let's put you in the cart. Let's go around. Are you in then?
I'm in.
Man, I'm in why what is the difference?
I trust you to handle that vehicle that
vessel.
Going around that track 220 miles an hour.
You could use does that make sense? You can use I can
use an example of let's say about I've never let's say
I've never shot a gun before and I say hey, let's go shooting. Come on.
Let's go.
No, no, I'm not. I'm not I'm not going
you're not gonna come with me. But let's say I'm like
a
Champion shooter I'm a sniper
in the military whatever something like that, right, you know, you've experienced
and it's a hey let's go shooting. Oh, yeah, you're
in you want to go because you know, I'm safe
with that vessel.
This is what our vessel for showing what's
happening down here for us is what we do or say
and when we become safe with that because we've
acknowledged.
The impact of what I do and say on you it
makes me safer. Does that make sense? Can you
kind of kind of feel that?
is your position is your
position in the cycle one of anger or
aggression
is your position that you suppress these
emotions and is your position this super logical
and robotic type kind
of cold but but robotic is that your position
or do you freeze up and shut down?
Identifying your your response. What is
it that we that I typically do in those
moments and owning the fact that
what I do has an impact on you in your
gut.
right understanding that and owning that
makes me immediately makes me safer for
them.
To be able to show up and to be present for
me.
Does that make sense?
Okay.
Now as we come to this the fourth step here.
This really is the most challenging and this is one that I'm
really going to try to.
Spend some time on.
It's the most challenging step.
to reconnecting
by far the most challenging step to reconnecting.
And so I want to show you a video that I
think kind of accurately depicts.
How challenging this is and kind
of what it's like to.
Move toward each other. Okay, so watch.
It's gone.
Go to pay he got to
play one. No wonder you.
Let her come to me.
I have crossed the Horizon to find
you.
I know your
name they have stolen the heart from inside you.
But this does not define you.
know
Who You Are
You truly are.
if
Man, there is so much.
in that
the fourth step
in
reconnecting with each other is to be able
to show up emotionally for
them
emotional presence
Is the key to love?
It's the critical step.
for us
if we're to be able to stop the enemy from destroying our
marriage.
So if you look at this.
in this video
to call
is the angry one, right?
her real name was to feedy but
you see she was lonely and isolated over there.
And safe, right she was safe from other people,
but she was also isolated from other people and they
were safe from her because of the water around her. She
couldn't go across that right? And so the little guy
I don't know his names a little demigod or something whatever they call him in
the in the show how people typically show up
for the angry one is like that right? Oh, right, they're
gonna whatever he was doing. He's like, I'm gonna fight you.
I'm gonna fight you back.
Right, and so I'm gonna throw this
Fireball here.
And then what Moana does?
is she's like, oh
they've stolen your heart.
It's not who you are.
And then she makes it safe for to feed
to cough to come to her and she
takes the steps.
Toward her right opens it up.
That's pretty vulnerable.
That's showing up.
And it's and it's being able to I just
imagine Moana being able to see the anger and go and
I know what that is. That's not who you are.
They've stolen the heart inside you.
And in a relationship I've stolen your heart.
And made you covered up with all that anger and made you
protect yourself that way and recognizing that I need
to step toward you.
As you come to me, even if you come to me in anger, I need
to be able to step towards you.
Vulnerably, right because there's no weapons
for her.
The other guy was going to fight her muscles and everything. She's like I'm
I'm here.
And as he as she recognizes that
moana's safe, right
and then hears that's not who you are. Do you see the eyebrows?
Whoo, it's like immediately like that baby last
night. Oh,
except it's like wait a minute. Something's happening. What is this? But it
wasn't scary and then
she goes dark right cools off.
And then they touch and then she replaces her
heart. She's like I get you. I understand you I'm here
for you. I showed up for you and then look what
happened.
That is the transformation that happens in a relationship
when we show up for each other emotionally. That's
really challenging. So we're gonna talk about that. I'm kind of
walk you through how to do this.
Here in just a just a minute.
so to do this
it takes vulnerability.
Right took Moana being vulnerable to do that.
This is you and your spouse.
Vulnerability is not very high on your priority list at this
point protection is right because you've you've
been robbed of this.
That's what the enemy has done to you is none to
all of us. He's robbed us of our
vulnerability our ability to be soft and
tender and open and transparent with you. So we put
on our fig leaves we cover up and protect ourselves.
So practically it looks like it looks
like you taking a step just like she did taking
a step and demonstrating verbally.
And understanding of what your spouse
is going through what they're doing or what they're
saying making sense of their anger.
To do that like I said last night if you if you
keep in mind that all Behavior makes sense in context
you've got to be able to make sense of
it. And so placing it in its proper context. Now's
like oh Moana I see the context there.
You've had your heart stolen you're angry
and you isolated in your loan and you
need connection. I'm gonna move towards you recognizing that
what you've been seeing or hearing from your spouse is
not that it's something else right? That's
the superhero super power that I
wanted you to I want you to have
practically
practically it means making sense of the
anger and seeing her exempt for
an example if she's angry makes seeing her
as attempting attempting to be significant in
your life.
It's making sense of his silence and seeing him
as scared to make a wrong move.
That's pretty typical for guys. We don't want to make a wrong
move.
In this the scenario, it's seeing April's
criticism of Corey.
As her being desperate for him to come and
show her how important she is to him.
And it's seen Cory walking away.
as being
afraid he'll never be good enough for
her.
So this kind of presence is very challenging.
Mainly because stepping toward our spouse.
means understanding
Kind of what's happening for them or at least seeking to
understand?
What they're feeling despite our senses telling them it's dangerous.
Right. Oh, it's there's this dangerous. This is bad territory
for me. Scary territory for me. I don't want to move into that moving toward
them anyway, and seeking to understand what's happening for
them. Even if you don't know and even if you don't know yourself, what's happening
and you say I don't know. I don't know. What's happening here
for me. I don't know what I'm feeling. I don't know this.
But I'm feeling something. Can you help me understand? What's happening
moving toward each other that way.
Okay, so can does it make sense?
What I'm saying about this being a vulnerable position to
take it's so
easy with our friends.
It's so easy with our friends to understand like it's so easy.
You know if your spouse is or if your friend is
telling you you know, the two of you you guys are out and she says
to you. My husband just doesn't
want to spend any time to me kind of using your example. He's always working on his car.
He said money spending time for me and she's gonna be
able to look, you know, I know that so awful.
Right and you've like, yes it is and you just
feel heard and understood.
You're not to fix anything. You just have to understand it that's
showing up.
Emotionally you can do that with your friends. You can do that with family you do
that, you know a lot of some family maybe unless you're
anyway, so you can do that for a
lot of people it's just more challenging with your spouse because our
friends are not attachment figures for us.
Our spouse is
it's the one designed for us.
so I hope it makes sense that this is a vulnerable position
to
It's like Moana facing taka in
the video many of you have probably felt like that. Like you've
probably seen like the person like this person you married. I don't
know who you are anymore. I'm gonna call you another name because that is
scary for me.
Our loneliness or our fear our pain comes out as anger.
And that's terrifying.
But when we show up emotionally for them when we
see their anger as something protective.
rather than dangerous
If they can let their guard down.
They don't have to now they don't have to be defensive because you show
up as their teammate.
You show up as their helper you show up
as their protector.
And they're better able to let their guard down the big problem with this
is because our anger has been so scary or
our distance has been so lonely
for us.
Moving toward them is terrifying and
it takes incredible courage.
right, it takes incredible courage, so
So then this next exercise this is
where I'm going to walk you through this really slowly because I
want to I want you to kind of experience.
with a with a
with the kind of a vignette here with a
statement that I hope one. I
don't want it to cause a fight but I
want you to be able to kind of get an experience. So this is what we typically do.
This is how I would typically respond if
you were to say something like that for me, this is how it typically respond.
So I want you to be able to have this experience.
and then
With each other kind of a normal what you might see as a
normal experience and then I want you to have an experience over
here of showing up for each
other.
And a vulnerable way.
Right. So this was a little challenging for
me for sure to try to put this together because I do want
you to get both sides mainly because I want you to
experience this so I'm gonna start with
the ladies
And what I have you kind of choose a statement here, you're too
focused on the kids activities, you're gone every weekend to this
tournament or that whatever it may be or you can do the
other one. All you want to do is play those stupid video games. You're never around when
I need you just pick one of those that you think's gonna win you in Academy
Award and and try to and try to
say that right. This may be long outside of your your kids
may be long gone or whatever. You may never have
played a video game in your life. I don't know just kind
of pick a pick a statement that you think
that you can kind of role play and I get it's always challenging to do that.
But I want you to do that and then
Then husbands, I want you to be able to say.
That can what what's the typical response for you?
What might you say or do? Okay, so so ladies
I want you to
make this statement.
to them
and then as soon as it gets quiet, then I'm gonna ask the
guys to respond to that. Okay, so take
however long it takes you to say that statement to each other
and do that.
Okay, you got that got no
and I get it. Yes his little challenging even little silly
but
Now now guys, I'm wondering how you
would typically respond to something
like that. Like how does it make
you what does the feeling that's coming up?
right
And if you're by yourself, imagine that being told
you and how would that feeling come up for you?
You have that.
How would you tell your spouse how you would typically respond or you
may have to ask them? How would I typically respond if you don't know how would
you typically respond?
Okay.
So now you have your kind of this your typical response.
Now man, I want you to have an opportunity.
To be able to show up emotionally.
For your for her by validating what you're hearing from her.
So let me give you an example, but I'm not going to use one of these. I want to use a different example
so that you don't steal anything. I say.
So ladies, let's say you say to your husband. You're spending
too much money on golf clubs.
Not that that's personal or anything, right? Not
that not that that's for or on
your anything golf related for me. You're spending
too much money.
husband you respond with
because you know, I'm feeling this right I'm feeling
this inside this. Oh, I've done something wrong. I'm not
a good husband. I'm a failure. I've made
a mistake. I've heard her feelings something all
this is going on for me, right? It's happening on the inside.
But I feel this Force to defend myself. That's
the cycle. And so I move toward her
and I say help me understand what you're feeling.
When you say that.
Right. So ladies
Say this your statement again.
To them whatever it was that you said and then
husbands I want you to be able to ask.
Help me understand how you're feeling when you
say that. Okay? Okay do that.
Okay.
It's you said the same statement.
Or you said the first statement and then it's a
here's how we typically respond for that. I would ignore that.
Or I would go do something else or I would
get angry and I would get defensive. That's my typical response to
you which would kind of throw us
into the cycle.
And then being able to understand how you're feeling in that moment defensive
attack.
Inadequate, whatever it may be for you feeling that.
Second one is okay. You say the same statement, but now you're kind
of pushing against that typical response right that
Force that's saying that's the
enemy saying remember that feeling is coming
up now, but you kind of you're stepping outside of this
cycle and you're saying help me understand what's happening
for you.
Right now, right what is going on for you?
Okay, so in in the scenario that I said.
She says to me, I'm worried. I was like, you
know help me understand how you feel. When you tell me that I'm spending too much money.
On golf stuff. I'm worried about the
finances because I'm not making my quote as
it work.
context
that's happening for her in showing up
for her.
I would say something like it makes sense to me that you're worried
because of your situation at work.
Right because what I didn't get before was the worry the
core emotion, I didn't get that.
I got criticism. You're spending too much money at
work. Right? Does that make sense?
Okay.
so
Men, you kind of heard that core
emotion.
You and and you tell her that you
understand it that makes sense to you. Right? Does it
make sense to you that she felt the way
she felt I'm assuming you shared that she shared
with you that core emotion. Does that make sense to you? If it
if it makes sense to you tell her?
Can you tell her?
How that feeling whatever scenario you
chose.
That it makes sense to you.
That's a big piece. Can you do that real quick?
Make sense to me that you're feeling that way.
having that
experience of saying it makes sense
to me.
Now that's you showing up for them.
emotionally
It's vulnerably you are not defending
it.
You're saying I can see how when I spend that
money. That scares you.
That makes sense to me that you would feel worried about
that. Okay. All right. Now I'm going to
do the same thing with the guys.
Gonna just reverse roles guys. Here's two more scenarios for
you. You're always too late at the office. You
always stay too late at the office. I'm the one here taking care of everything.
Or all you do is criticize and complained you you ever
think that maybe you're not perfect either.
So I want you to pick one of those guys.
I want you to share that.
with her
Okay, pick one of those do that now.
Okay, good. You said that Now ladies?
Pay attention how you're feeling with that?
And tell him this is how this is what
happens to me. This is my this would be my typical response to
something along that line telling me whether this
is defensiveness or whatever is coming up.
Just hurt or whatever from that attack. And then how
would you typically respond tell him how you would kind of
typically respond to that?
Okay, so now ladies I want you to have an opportunity to
show up.
for him
by validating what he's saying? So for example
husbands, you say you never want to have sex.
Because I know that's never come up in your relationship before
so it's a perfectly rare example wife you
respond with help me understand.
How how you feel when you say that? So whatever statement you
said guys?
Say ask her how she feels.
when or
Sorry, you know what? I mean?
Ladies asking him how he's feeling when he
says that to you.
Only share guys only share that core emotion that
comes up.
okay, so in my scenario is
I say I feel unwanted.
When we're not having sex and I worry I'm not good enough for you.
And showing up for them.
You would say something like I can understand that you feel unwanted when
we're not having sex and that you would worry that you're
not good enough for me.
That makes sense to me. So ladies, you've heard this core
motion from him. He shared this with you. This is what's coming
up for him.
You tell him that you understand it that it makes sense to you.
Right. Does that make sense to you using your scenario? Tell him?
That what you heard that that it makes
sense to you.
So a lot of times when we're trying to
you know, I hear a lot of couples and and and the office.
Oh, yes.
So you say help me understand?
Right three words. It'll save your life.
Help me understand. I want it to make
sense, right the idea is if it
doesn't make sense to you say that doesn't make sense,
but I really want to understand it.
Move toward him with this. I don't
know right because there's a guy said here. Sometimes I can't label
that's it, or I'm trying to explain it. And I don't know that it's coming out,
right?
I've been there.
And to be able to say listen, I don't understand
that. I really want to can you help me understand? Can you
help me make sense of this?
Because a lot if we find the right context
Then we can we can make sense of it.
Right. Everything makes sense in context.
Right. I look back at how often use the example of
9/11.
We all look at that and go when what a vicious attack.
If you can make sense of it, I'm not
saying that we have to agree with what's happening in our
relationship. But if you can make sense of it,
right that moves you toward understanding I can
make sense of that in context.
in context of 2100 years
Right of Muslims feeling that way I can see that I can
see what would happen. It doesn't I don't have to agree with
it. I don't have to like it. I hate it, but
I understand it. This is where we relationship. Right?
And the reality is I mean look at Democrats
and Republicans for crying out loud. It's the same cycle on
a larger scale.
Right, they're both trying to do something, right? It
just doesn't look like it from the other side.
So this reason I think a marriage and family therapist like Jeff back
there or whatever would make a really good president.
So, okay.
So how does it feel to be validated? How does
it feel to to be to get
gotten or to feel felt?
How's it feel?
Feels relieving, right? It feels safe. It
feels secure. I got somebody on my team.
I got somebody who gets me.
Somebody who understands me.
Understanding is crucial.
And I want to say at this point some people are going to
kind of worry. Well, we have this problem. How do we solve that? Here's the
deal. You are the expert in your problem, not me.
What keeps you from solving that problem is understanding what's
happening for each other?
I have a couple that I've worked I've been working with them for
probably a year now.
And they've been married about
12 13 years or so, and he
wanted another child.
Because they're probably 14 years because they're
they're daughter is about 12
years old.
And he's wanting another child.
And she already has two she has one from a previous relationship. And
and so she's I don't want anymore children.
And so as I've been working with them and they come because
then they'll argue about this and he's wanting another child. What happens
for him? Is he throws himself into the soccer
and being a great soccer dad and
being a great soccer coach because he's good at that. He's good
at connecting with his daughter and
being a good coach. He's adequate he's good enough for
her.
Right, so he throws himself into that.
Well, how do you think the wife feels?
lonely
unwanted unimportant
all of those. Yes.
So do you think she wants to have another child?
No, absolutely not because what will that
do in her mind that just says that'll give him all these
many more years of being without me. I don't want to live that
many more years being lonely.
And so how's it feel being him?
Criticized never be good enough all of
those things because out of her loneliness.
Kind of like April in the scenario out of her loneliness. She's critical.
You never want to spend time with me. You're always throwing yourself into the
kids.
You're going to this Tournament of that every other weekend.
Whatever, right so he feels good. So he
wants another child so he can have something that he's good at in his
mind. He's not a good husband. He's an inadequate.
Husband, he's a failure as a husband. So he wants another kid because he's good at
that.
Something that makes him feel good. So as we've been doing this work for
them.
They've been recognizing and they've been able to show up. It makes
sense to her. She says it makes sense to me that you
would want another child because you don't feel good enough to
me. You feel like you can never do anything good enough for me
in my eyes or you know
And he's like it makes sense to me that you would
not want to have another child because you already feel lonely
without me.
Why would you want to spend all of these years?
All 18 more years lonely.
That makes sense.
Does that make sense to you how that's working, you know
where they are now.
Not pregnant not pregnant, you know where they
are now.
She's like
I'd love to have another child with you.
And he said to her.
I have you.
I have that kind of what Jeff was saying about the lady putting her
ring on this is what happens.
He wanted another child to protect him. She doesn't want another
child to protect her now. She wants a child to protect him
and he doesn't want a child to protect her. Does that make sense?
That's what the cycle is doing to us.
That's what it's doing to us. That's how it's destroying us.
So I completely got off. This is again why I have to have paper in front of me.
I want you to be able to hear the difference in the responses. Our first response
our typical response. Is this kind of
staying away from each other?
Taking a defensive stance.
Focusing on protecting ourselves. And the second
is you being focused on the other you being all about her
you're being all about him and their feelings.
The first one takes you headlong into the cycle
the second one allows you to step outside of
it.
And the second one has the ability to soften
the other.
to cough
It softens when I have a teammate when
I have somebody who gets me man.
If somebody who shows me that I'm loved and shows me that I'm important.
I can do anything.
right 12 disciples Matthew 28
Right, they'll die for him because he's with them.
So I hope you're seeing this like,
okay. Sorry, I got one more side. I didn't show you this one.
It's an important point.
The second one here is a very challenging position.
We'll say that before I get to this next slide second
one. Here's an incredibly different position because
it takes you being vulnerable to be
emotionally present.
All the while fighting off that sense of being attacked. That's why
it's vulnerable. It's vulnerable to share. Yes. It's also vulnerable
to get it.
To understand it I often liken it to confessing to a
crime that you didn't commit.
Or at least that you didn't intend to commit.
Saying I get it. It makes sense to me.
So and being that many of you have kind of lived this cycle already
to the live this point
to this point in your life with without any knowledge of
the cycle.
The outcome has made it necessary for you to avoid that's why I
kind of stepping out and moving toward them. You would only do that. If you
have like this full suit of armor on and all I'm asking you
is to recognize they're not your enemy.
Move toward them and understand what's happening
Moana moving toward to kah,
you're not the enemy.
I'm not going to be afraid of your anger anymore.
I'm not afraid of your distance anymore. It
makes sense to me.
So so at an important point for you
to understand is this go to this next slide there. I
think we
have that
if you're the angry or aggressive one.
You must understand the damage your anger has
done.
To your spouse and how it's kept them from coming towards you
to offer what you need.
I guess we don't have.
The maybe that one's not up there. Maybe I I may
have I may have added that and forgot to
tell you my fault.
So I'll say it again. If you're the angry one or you're the aggressive
one. You must understand the damage your anger has
done to your spouse.
Yes.
Yeah, this is where it's it's first make sense of
it. It understand Hey listen,
I I don't know what's happened. It's hard for me to understand and at
some point listen it may be this is where I
may need some if I'm if we're in a place and I just don't understand it
is where I mean go seek some help. I I really
need to understand it. The good news is putting ourselves
in a position in a vulnerable place to try to
seek to understand.
One is calming for us and calming for them. And then
when we're calm, we're more likely to be able to verbalize something
even more deep for
us because it could be something it it what
we refer to as a block. There is
something there's this block for me to be able to say to you what I
want you to get.
Because it's really vulnerable too vulnerable for
me to share with you.
So and we can talk about later and I'll even give you my email if you want to email me
and then we can kind of do that back and forth to try to help a little bit because that
is challenging. It's just an outcome of the cycle that
creates a place where I don't understand what you're doing.
So we can kind of talk about that a little bit more.
But we really must understand the damage that
we've done to our spouse.
And how it's kept them from coming toward toward a
toward us or toward you to offer what
you need. So I totally understand that anger or
the distance or whatever is is an attempt
to be heard. What you need to understand is divisive. It's
not connecting.
If this is true for you, and you're recognizing that
you're the angry one, I'm praying you'll tell
your spouse that you get it that how scary your
anger must be for them. Right in order to try
to help them feel safer with you and tell them that you
want them to know what's really happening for you.
So I hope you're seeing.
The cycle here as your your enemy.
It really does seek to turn us.
from lovers into enemies
And so this this kind of brings me back full circle.
This brings us all full circle.
Back to the Garden where the enemy first showed up
in our marriage.
if you remember back to Genesis 3, right we talked about Genesis 2:18
to 28 if you remember back to Genesis 3
After listen, after listening to the enemy and then
sinning disobeying and sinning.
God came to them.
And they were hiding remember.
And he says I heard you.
He said where are you who he knows where they are, right, of course.
He says I was I was hiding.
Because I was naked and I was afraid and that's why who
told you that you were naked right? Remember how defensive Adam
became in that moment.
When God when I got asked where they were who told you you were
naked how defensive when God asked him and he told me he was naked.
Adam said that woman you gave to
be with me.
That woman you gave me to be with me. She gave
it to me and I ate.
This was the beginning of conflict.
In the garden and I think Satan learned in that moment.
A very powerful tool. This is how he can get in
between us.
This is how he can destroy the connection that we have.
if we don't realize
the work he's doing to destroy us.
We're doomed to stay trapped in it.
And if we never get out of it.
we're always going to be fighting each other
to try to get to it to try to get to this love
that we once have we're going to try to achieve this love
that we
started off with so many years ago.
Well forever be fighting for the incredible marriage.
that we desire
We're always going to be fighting for that the last thing love that
we hope to share.
the warm and intimate peaceful
Connecting love that we were supposed to have. This is
what the enemy is trying to destroy us from it's this
warm and peaceful.
Intimate love that. God gave us to enjoy.
until death to his part
not until this cycle tears us
apart. So this kind of love.
Is what I want you I want to show you this video.
And I'm not going to set it up for you, and I'm not going to come back up after
it's over.
My Hope Is that it's it gets
My hope is that it inspires you.
My hope is that it helps you see this is
the kind of love.
That I want for you and this is the kind of love that God
wants for you.
But this is the kind of love that the enemy wants to destroy.
Okay.
I want to
fall in love at 85.
Go on shuffleboard dates and dance to Hip
Hop from 95.
We'd Rock matching tracksuits and rope gold
chains.
We'd look like Run DMC but in their old age.
We'd take aerobics classes and whereby focal
glasses and eat at IHOP and hold hands
at Sunday masses and when it comes to the bedroom.
Well, nothing much would happen the bedroom because we're 85.
but we would still be down to take a walk or take a driver sit
and talk or have a drink watch the passage by ask each
other why and how and who and where and
when and then we'd laugh and cry again about the people we
I would touch her withered skin.
And comment on how thin it is to keep in something infinite.
And she would smile sweet and blush and tell me that I think
too much.
She's right. I think too much.
It's always been a problem.
But then again, that's how I made my green like the Goblin.
When I was in my twenties, I was eating Top Ramen
counting up my pennies saving up to go food shopping,
but now I'm 85.
And somehow I feel more alive.
I turn my hearing aid up and bumped Jurassic 5.
And when it comes to the bedroom.
well, hopefully
every once in a while.
She lets me knock her boots into the floor patterns of
our bedposts then hold her head close like death
isn't chasing us.
Planning on erasing us and replacing us with better
versions of us reshaping us
remaking us then recreating us with new identities
so we can make new memories hush little
baby learn to walk and talk and think and
lie and feel and fight and love and die and
never get the answers why she tips to
join of grass and wheatgrass and we get high.
Her hair is silver as the moon in Miami
sky.
We still pop Hills, but it's not the Xanax
anymore.
Whenever we can't sleep we listen to the ocean floor.
She got a sound of the CCD for me from the Brookstone store and
ever since I've been snoring like a
Like a really good metaphor for snoring. Sorry I
go blank sometimes.
What I'm 85.
I'm not complaining. I'm just happy that I'm still alive and happy
that I have my better half by my side
Super Flash. He doesn't look a day over 65.
When I first saw I was totally in
awe.
She was classical so I was like Yo Yo
Ma.
And that was all it took.
A single look and I was shook I fell for
like some loose shingles from our Spanish roof.
And I'm a lover till she loses every last root and has
to glue Dentures to her gums to chew solid food.
Oh.
Now that's real love, dude.
That's some push comes to shove love.
Not when it's convenient, love.
hospital bed love
Feed her ice chips love.
Never leave the room.
sleeping in the chair
pray to up above love.
Have to pull the plug.
Miss her in my bones love.
Everything about her love die within
a month love can't live without her love.
love
The only reason that we are a lie.
And none of us should have to wait until 85.